yesterday we discussed an article that
has been getting some attention online
mainly because feminists seem to really
like it the article was written by a
woman who complains about all the
cooking that she did during her marriage
and she would cook while her husband was
at work and was it was very it became
very traumatizing for her to have to do
all this cooking because she decided
that she didn't she didn't find it
exciting anymore it wasn't fulfilling
so she boycotted and said I'm not gonna
cook anymore than her marriage fell
apart and now she has vowed to never
cook a meal for another man ever again
the whole thing was it was a very bitter
very angry very self-centered
melodramatic diatribe well I got a few
emails in response to that discussion I
wanted to share one email that came in
this is from Katherine she says Matt
your podcast today was very offensive to
me the woman you mocked had legitimate
concerns one of the reasons my own
marriage fell apart is because I was
expected to do all the cooking and all
the cleaning women are tired of that
feminism doesn't hurt a marriage you
can't have a healthy marriage without
feminism marriage is last if they are
equal all caps period all caps okay so
you can't have a healthy marriage
without feminism and other emails it
echoed basically that same sentiment and
first of all listen I don't mean to be
cruel or anything like that that's but
but I do wonder how someone who is
divorced can make pronouncements about
what constitutes a healthy marriage you
you know I find this a lot whenever I
talk about marriage there are people who
they'll begin by admitting that they've
been divorced at least once and then
they'll go on to talk about and give all
their wisdom and what makes a good
healthy marriage and so on and so forth
I mean is it is it possible that you
might have some faulty ideas about
marriage and perhaps that's something
that fed into the fact that you're no
longer married I mean isn't that
something
that certainly is something that you
should maybe look into I don't know but
I do think that the opposite is the case
your feminism is not essential to a
healthy marriage feminism destroys
marriage not just feminism by the way
but any ISM any ISM whatsoever marriage
is not a place for isms you can't go
into a marriage with with some kind of
political or ideological system as your
guiding principle in the marriage itself
I'm not saying that you know you can't
have a political or ideology ideological
system and be married I'm saying that
that system cannot be what what makes
your marriage function so even though
I'm a conservative I also I would never
say well you can't have a healthy
marriage without conservatism marriage
really has nothing to do with the
conservative political ideology or at
least it's only it's only connected in a
very secondary sort of way marriage
depends on the love and devotion that
both spouses have towards each other
that's what makes a healthy marriage
that's that's really it if you try to
filter that love and devotion through an
ideology especially in ideology like
feminism you're you're you're gonna be
in trouble because it complicates things
it dilutes things it throws your
priorities all out of whack so I have
found that maintaining a successful
marriage is extremely simple now I won't
say it's easy all the time and I
certainly won't say that I personally
have come anywhere close to mastering
the arts of maintaining you know of
mastering the art of marriage I suppose
I'm I'm no expert or guru but I do know
that it's simple there are a lot of
things that we can we can tell the
answer is simple even if it's hard
sometimes to do so it's it's simple with
me it's not complicated you just you
love the other person be willing to
sacrifice for them make their needs and
their desires a priority to you and
and and that's that's kind of it I think
if you do that you'll be fine you'll be
able to get through any challenge if you
keep if you do that and then here's the
other thing this is this is part of that
but you have to serve your spouse
without keeping score and this is where
feminism really screws things up I think
it's with the scorekeeping because once
you get into the scorekeeping you're in
trouble there has never been a healthy
or good or joyful marriage in history
with a scoreboard anytime there's that
there's a scoreboard in a marriage that
once you start once you once you notice
that there's a scoreboard like hanging
in your living room at least a
metaphorical scoreboard once you notice
that you got to go to the marriage
counselor because you're you're in
trouble good marriages don't have
scoreboards competitiveness destroys a
marriage at least a certain kind of
competitiveness my wife and I are
competitive in in in other kinds of ways
like we're competitive when it comes to
board games and I'm Way better at those
we're competitive about who's the better
driver I am by a mile
we're competitive about about parallel
parking again I'm better at that we're
competitive about about who can guess
the ending of TV shows and movies
anytime we're watching a TV show or a
movie you know who can who can guess
what the twists are gonna be and
everything once again I kneel almost
every single time so I'm better there as
well but there's that kind I think that
kind of competitive competitiveness is
is okay although although it can get a
bit intense at times I'm not gonna lie I
mean my wife and I have probably gone to
bed angry at each other on more than a
few occasions because of board games so
that has happened but I think the really
bad kinds of competitions are the
competitions over who works the hardest
who does more around the house who did
this who did that the competitiveness
that disguises itself as a desire for
equality that's
that's the stuff that kills the marriage
and that's what feminism brings into the
marriage and that's why it is lethal to
a marriage and you notice something
about that whenever somebody complains
or you know says that they want equality
in their marriage it always and have you
noticed this when someone says oh I just
want my marriage to be equal when they
say that it always involves them doing
less and the other person doing more
have you noticed that so someone will
say I want things to be equal and what
they mean is I want my spouse to doom to
do the dishes more often or whatever you
never hear anyone say I want things to
be equal so I'll do the dishes that
never happens so this desire for
equality this scorekeeping it's always
self-serving anytime someone in a
marriage checks the scoreboard they're
always going to discover that they're
ahead in that they've done more they've
done more around the house so now they
get to kick back and let their spouse
catch up that's the that's what's really
fascinating is that anytime you look at
the scoreboard you're always going to be
ahead that's the problem with the
scoreboard the woman who sent the email
Katherine she says that in her former
marriage she was expected to do all the
cooking and all the cleaning and so the
question is what did her husband do
maybe he did nothing maybe he was a
worthless useless oath possible there
are people like that at marriages who
knows but oftentimes you find that when
one spouse is going on about I always am
the one who does this whatever this is
very often there are a million other
things that the other person always does
on their own so I think this attitude
just doesn't work a marriage can't work
this way it can only work if your first
priority is to serve your spouse and
your family but again this is the
problem with feminism feminism wants
nothing to
do with that feminism doesn't want a
woman to serve her husband and her
children you're never gonna hear a
feminist say that you're never gonna
hear a feminist say talk about serving
their husbands serving that to a
feminist the idea of serving anyone
especially a man is is repulsive
and that's why it just it doesn't work
in a marriage because that's what
marriage is they say I can't serve
that's demeaning that's degrading that's
belittling well if you if you can't
serve if you don't want to serve someone
then don't get married if you want if
you're a woman you're not interested in
serving your husband then don't get
married it's not for you
and if you're a man and you're not
interested in serving your wife then
don't get married you're not man enough
for marriage you're not strong enough
you're not you're not mature enough if
you're not interested in serving because
that's what marriage is and by the way
you know I'm not trying to paint some
unrealistic portrait hear people say
well marriage isn't 50/50 it's 100 100
because you always give a hundred
percent to your spouse well yeah but
nobody gives literally 100 percent all
the time
nobody is perfectly selfless right
nobody is so I'm not saying that in a
marriage your sole single only priority
all the time is the happiness of your
spouse it's it's not as if we should
have no concern for our own happiness
I'm not saying that that would obviously
that would obviously be absurd working
with beings after all and I and I do
think sometimes people can go too far in
the other direction when they're making
the point that well marriage is about
service is about giving to the other
person and it's not about you it's about
them so on and so forth that's true but
at the same time we're not supposed to
be martyrs you know you don't want to
martyr yourself in a marriage because
that's not healthy either so but that's
part of the service I think is
recognizing that your spouse is going to
be selfish sometimes needs to be selfish
sometimes really selfish just in the
sense of tending to their own happiness
as well getting a break and I could say
in in in my marriage my wife I as I said
we're not marriage experts by any
stretch of the imagination I think we
need to get a few more decades in before
we could call ourselves that but one
thing that we did figure out early on
that's not hard to figure out pretty
seems pretty obvious is that we both
need to give each other breaks as often
as possible that's just a I think it's a
really important part of important part
of marriage so it's it's become kind of
an organic thing for us it's not
systematic so there's no scoreboard for
this we're not like keeping track of how
many minutes of a break each person has
gotten and making sure it's exactly even
we don't do that but I'll watch the kids
sometimes so that my wife can go out on
her own do her own thing she'll watch
them for me and so if she's got
something she wants to do like she wants
to go out for drinks with a with her
friends or she wants to go to a women's
group thing at church or whatever the
case may be I considered it I consider
it a high priority to make sure that she
can do that because I know that she
needs that time and she recognizes the
same for me so I can say that in seven
years of marriage pretty much any time
that I've said to my wife hey I want to
go out with some friends or I want to go
fishing on Saturday morning pretty much
any time I've said that she's she's said
yeah absolutely
let's try to make that happen and so I
try to do the same for hurt I think I
think that's important too but the the
general idea the underlying thing in a
marriage is still one of service and of
kind of looking after the other person
and that's why feminism that's why
feminism makes a marriage dysfunctional
I think feminism makes everything
dysfunctional feminism doesn't really
feminism doesn't doesn't work in any
context whether it's at work or anywhere
else in society but especially in a
marriage it doesn't work because
feminism is always about keeping track
of where the man is and then making sure
that that the woman is exactly even
or even a little bit ahead like it's
always about that and it just doesn't
work and that's why I'm I've always been
uncomfortable with this idea of marriage
as an equal partnership I think I've
talked about this before that's that's
the the popular modern enlightened thing
is to say well my marriage is an equal
partnership and in a sense yeah marriage
is obviously a partnership and in a
sense it is equal in that you're both
serving and giving to the other person
so in that way
you could call it equal nobody is
inferior to the other person so you can
call it equal in that sense but those
are the only senses where marriages is
is or can be or should be equal in in
many ways it's not equal it's not equal
first of all because men and women are
different
not that one is superior and the other
is in fear but they're just different
you're just a different person so you're
not the same you are not literally equal
to the other you are different and you
also have different skills you have
different you have different strengths
that you bring to the table and so it's
not equal in that sense either and just
the point is that I think most of the
time and you could probably think about
this in your own life or in your own
marriage anytime that you've stopped and
thought to yourself well is this equal
is is everything equal right now any
time you've stopped and thought that to
yourself it's probably always in a
selfish way you know it's always in it's
a selfish way for yourself in an
accusatory way towards your spouse and
that's the problem with it and that's
the problem with feminism in a marriage
all right so I've been getting some
messages about essential oils now I
don't want to get I'm not gonna get into
detail about essential oils I just I
made a joke about essential oils on
Twitter yesterday and so I've been I've
been getting all the essential oil
defenders coming after me and I'll admit
I have no idea what essential oils are I
don't know what they are I have no idea
I just I I keep hearing about the
my wife talks about them I don't know if
she uses them or not maybe we have
essential oils in the house I don't know
where they would be if we had them maybe
she doesn't her friends talk about them
all the time
anytime there's sickness in the house
like someone has a cold or the flu or
whatever or a stomach bug what everyone
is telling us oh you got to get
essential oils essential oils I don't
know what they're the only oil is I know
about our olive oil and then the oil
that you put in your car those are
pretty essential to my life but I don't
think that's what they're referring to
what I will say is this from the
messages people have been sending me
about essential oils the one word that
keeps coming up is people are telling me
that essential oils are are homeopathic
and I do know that homeopathic is Latin
for scam I know that so anytime you're
telling you if it's homeopathic it
doesn't work and also someone on Twitter
said to me yesterday they said well
people have been using essential oils
for hundreds of years it's a it has to
be better than modern medicine people
have been using it for a long time
you see I don't understand that approach
I don't understand that attitude I don't
understand advocating for a certain
medicine a certain medicinal approach by
saying that people did it 150 years ago
people died from colds 150 years ago the
life expectancy was like 55 back then
why would I want to practice their
version of medicine Society has has
there are many ways in which modern
society has not progressed and has
actually regressed and I'd be the first
to point that out but one area where I
think we should be all able to agree one
area where there has been pretty much a
steady unbroken progression is in the
area of medicine our medicine is
definitely better now than it was at any
other point in history I don't think
there's any doubt about that and you can
see that in any measurable whatever
measurable you want to look at whether
its life expectancy infant mortality
whatever it is it's just in every
conceivable way our medicine is is
better now so I'm I'll generally stick
with the modern versions when it comes
to that but I will also say that I do
believe
that the psychosomatic placebo effect is
a real thing and it and in it and it
does work in that way so if you really
believe if you really believe that a
certain random thing like oil makes you
healthier then it may not really be
making you healthier but it will make
you feel better so in that sense go
ahead and do it
I used to swear by Zicam I don't know if
you've heard of as I can but it's you
can find it in the in the cold and flu
section of the drugstore and so I used
to take as I came all the time and I
would swear by it I used to swear that
it was a wonder drug because any time I
felt even slightly a little bit sick I
would take Zicam and then it would go
away and so I went through about two
years and I never got a cold I never got
sick and I would tell everybody it's I
would I would preach the good news of
Zicam to everyone everyone that would
listen I would tell them I would say I'm
telling you as I cam is what is keeping
me healthy
zai cam will make me immortal I believe
but then one day I happened to stumble
across an article that someone shared on
Facebook claiming that Zicam is a scam
and it doesn't actually work and so then
I started researching it and I
discovered that there is no evidence or
proof whatsoever that Zicam really does
anything and as soon as I discovered
that as I cam stop working and then I
started getting colds again so there was
I had my mind had I had been tricked I
had tricked myself into feeling better
and then the illusion fell apart and and
it didn't work anymore the placebo
effect was destroyed so what I'm saying
is you know if the essential oils are
homeopathic then I'm pretty sure they
don't do anything but if you believe
that they do something then keep
believing it and don't research it don't
look it up
ignorance is bliss if you believe in it
then it in some way it will make you
feel better and that's and that's great
as far as I'm concerned all right one
last thing Rudolph the Red Nosed
Reindeer is coming under fire The
Huffington Post put out a video this
week highlighting the problematic
elements of the story the story
encourages bullying and races
for one thing and homophobia somehow I
don't remember there being a gay
reindeer in the story but apparently
maybe there was there's homophobia look
I think all of these criticisms are
perfectly valid and important and
warranted as I'm sure you agree but as
I've been thinking about this since
Huffington Post brought it up and you
know I've been thinking about Rudolph
the red-nosed reindeer now and I've
realized that there's a bigger problem
with the story and it has to do with
plausibility now stay with me here
because I know you're thinking what are
you talking about man what a story about
a flying reindeer how is that
implausible well I know on the surface
it seems like it makes perfect sense but
just let's review let's just think about
this for a second and somehow The
Huffington Post they missed this okay
they're criticizing all these other
parts they missed this part of the story
Santa is about to head out with all the
toys but then he sees that it's foggy so
he goes well we're gonna have to cancel
Christmas know Christmas it's foggy
we can't go out we can't see you know
how am I supposed to fly this sleigh
when I can't see but then he says hey
hold on a second where's that freak with
the shiny nose yeah get him in here
and and and and maybe he can finally be
of some use and so they fly off with
Rudolph leading the way through the fog
and everybody lead lives happily ever
after right
not so fast this doesn't actually make
sense think about it
Santa was about to cancel Christmas
because of a patch of fog but then
Rudolph bailed him out so am I supposed
to believe that Santa had never run into
fog before he flies around the entire
world in December and he never hit bad
weather never fog never a snowstorm
never never a blizzard never a rainstorm
nothing he had no contingency plan for
bad weather and had to rely on the
convenient facial deformity of a
socially scorned reindeer not to mention
he carries out this operation at night
and this is the first time he ever
needed a headlights something is not
adding up here that's all I'm saying
now I know you might argue and I
about this - I said well well we don't
know exactly when the Rudolf story took
place maybe it was maybe this was um
Santa's first-ever mission
well that doesn't work either watch the
show do your research look at the kinds
of toys that are in Santa's Santa's sack
that he's bringing to all the kids there
are toy trains in there what does that
tell you
well steam locomotives didn't exist
before the 19th century Saint Nick was
born in the fourth century that's 1500
years that means he was on the job for
at least 1500 years and never once had
he dealt with fog in 1500 years I'm not
behind it I'm just not buying now don't
get me wrong I don't doubt the general
historical veracity of Santa and Rudolph
I'm just saying
something is wrong here Santa wanted
Rudolph on that sleigh but it had
nothing to do with the fog so what was
the real reason I don't know but I'm
gonna find out cue dramatic music and I
want to thank a few posts for bringing
up this subject so that maybe finally we
can get to the bottom of all of these
mysteries hope you guys have a great
weekend and I'll talk to you next week
Godspeed